dans ces lignes passent 20000 volts un
réseau électrique alimentant ben et les
communes avoisinantes
ce matin quatre techniciens
interviennent sur un kilomètre de ligne
c'est un chantier dit est donc réalisée
sous tension c'est à dire que la ligne
est maintenu sous tension et donc
l'opération consiste à poser ce qu'on
appelle des dispositifs anti paille donc
pour éviter que les fétu de paille ne
touche la ligne et les férus oh le
poteau en même temps ce qui provoquerait
des courts-circuits et donc des
microcoupures pour nos clients de la
paille projetés lors des moissons ou de
grands vents le dispositif c'est ça une
sorte de pince à linge
installé à 13 mètres de hauteur ils ont
une jauge graduée
c'est notre distance à respecter donc
faut pas qu'on s'approche ce qu'on
appelle à plus de 6 p donc les au pcd
des éléments de protection est un
élément de protection correspond à 10 cm
donc en montant faut qu'on respecte nous
si je paye donc 60 cm par rapport à la
ligne qui est sous tension donc en
permanence ils surveillent leur leurs
mouvements et leurs distances par
rapport au réseau des dispositifs de
protection des oiseaux ont aussi été
installés les yvelines compte 5000 km de
lignes électriques 700 sont aériennes